now how do you know
whether a deal is a good deal or not so
there's three things
that you want to do when you're buying a
house there's three things you want to
look for would you like to know what
they are if you would give me a thumbs
up
okay we're going to be finding houses
today these are the three things and
this is re
this is pop this is possibly the most
technical part of the crash course so
get ready to listen fully
take good notes because this is a little
bit
facts and formulas and figures and you
need to learn these
i failed in school but believe me i
learned these formulas and it changed my
life
so the three things these are the three
golden rules number one
is if you're buying a property you want
to buy it
below market value this is bmv
you never pay the full asking price on a
house
below market value now later on we're
going to talk about how to do that
how to negotiate how to
um how to how to know if a property what
the true market value is of a property
but that's the first golden rule number
two
you want to make sure that when you buy
a property you have a good
return on investment
these are all the jargon terms that
you'll hear and you need to learn what
they are
so if someone's if if an investor says
to you would you be able to find me a
good bmv deal with a high roi
you're like yeah of course you're
speaking my language
whereas whereas maybe previously you
would have been you would have been like
a bm a bm what
all right so next a bmv deal below
market value
with good roi what what does roi mean
roi means the money that you're putting
into the deal it needs to give you a
good
cash on cash return and i'm going to
show you shortly
how to calculate and how to work out
the return on investment the smart way
because a lot of people do this wrong
and you need to master these
calculations
and then the last thing that you need
is e c a
and e c a stands for
expected capital
appreciation let me tell you something
if you can find properties
that tick all of these boxes
they're below market value they're good
return on investment
and there's expected capital
appreciation in the area
you will succeed in
this business and what i want to show
you today
is i want to show you exactly in like
everywhere
how to do this how to find
these deals and how to calculate these
formulas
if that's okay with you is that okay
all right good so write that down
bmv so bmv how do you get a deal below
market value
what do you do well first thing is this
when you ring up an estate agent
what most people do is they'll go and
view 100 houses and they'll just offer
on everything
you know that's stupid you don't want to
do that when you ring up an estate agent
you want to tell them that you're
looking for properties that are below
market value up front
hey i'm looking for property deals um
i'm looking for deals i'm very serious
i'm so serious i even went through the
samuel leeds
property investors crash course and
i'm looking to buy a property
and i'm looking to buy something below
market value as i am an investor do you
have any deals or any motivated sellers
and a lot of them are going to go no we
don't
get out of here no we're fine
but i'd rather that i'd rather get
rejected on the phone
than do what most people do what most
people do is they'll go
they'll book a viewing they'll go and
look around the house
they'll spend half an hour talking to
the agent about the weather
and then they'll go home and then
they'll call the agent and then they'll
put forward 20
below market value offer and then the
estate agent's like thanks for wasting
my time
and then you've wasted your time their
time
it's a terrible approach you're better
off to be upfront right from the
beginning
next thing as well if you find a
property online
okay you can ring up and you can just
say hey i've seen a property
it's on the market for a hundred
thousand pounds on church road
and they'll say yes how can i help you
you'll say look to be honest
i'm only likely going to be able to
offer about 90 000 pounds
i don't want to offend anybody but is it
worth me booking your viewing or not
and if they say no it's not worth
booking a view and they'll never accept
that then don't book a view and go
alright no worries thanks for your time
have you got any other properties where
they might be a bit more motivated
it's not a difficult phone conversation
to have you're going to be having those
types of calls today by the way
okay and and the the people that win
today
are going to be the people that take the
most action like when i give you guys a
working exercise
it is not a freaking break
okay it is a working exercise
if i say right i've got 20 minutes and
i'm going to go and phone these people
go
don't think oh well i get the principal
i get the gist
i'll phone them next week but now i'll
just reflect on the lesson that samuel
gave me
no there are observers and there are
participators how many of you are
committed
and ready to be a participator give me a
thumbs up
right return on investment
how do you get a good return on
investment well firstly
um you know let me show you how to
calculate the return on investment first
what's the average house price in the uk
someone write it down and show me the
average house price
because you need to be able to calculate
these things really well
someone said uh uh lewis did 160 grand
uh address said 200 grand a few people
saying 200 grand
to 40. it's actually around about 240
however let's just just to keep the math
simple let's say that we find a house
for 200 grand
right and let's say we're going to rent
the house out
what's that what's the average rent for
a 200 grand house
nice little two-bed house someone write
down
someone's saying a grand uh
someone's saying 750
um 900. all right so
right now the average rent for a 200
grand house
probably gonna be about 800 pound
per month so how do you work out
what the return on investment is on that
house
you know if you buy an ass for 200 grand
and you're renting out for 800
a month what's the return on investment
so here's how you work out the return on
investment
this is the formula and you might want
to write this down so firstly
this is the formula you need to take the
annual
profit divided by
the total investment
times 100 annual profit divided by the
total investment times 100 is equal to
the roi that's the formula
so if if so so if we know that then we
can move to the next stage
so the return and by the way if you're
wanting to sell something you might be
thinking but sammy i just want to sell
deals
i just want to get free houses no
unless you know exactly how to calculate
the return on investment
no one will ever buy a deal from you
because when
the first thing you're going to say to a
deal an investor is to say
i found this house it's a really good
house the return on investment
works out about 10 and it's also
20 below market
value if you don't know how to calculate
the market value in the return on
investment
you're done you're finished so this is
really important you get this this is
not theoretical this is
practical and you need it okay give me a
thumbs up if you understand
good thank you so the annual profit
divided by the total investment and
what's the total investment the total
investment is the total cash investment
that's needed
so let's work out how to work out what
this is so if you're buying a house for
200 grand
is it going to cost you 200 000 cash
to buy the house thumbs up or thumbs
down or yes or no no it's not
because you're not going to buy the
house for cash you're going to get a
mortgage on the house
so you're going to put down a deposit
and the deposit is going to be about 25
percent
okay uh ashley that's right 50 grand
so the deposit is going to be about 50
grand
so 50 grand is part of your total
investment however
is your deposit the only thing that
you're gonna need in order to buy a
house yes or no no it's not
what else are you gonna need you're
gonna need
uh probably stamp duty
you're gonna need uh fees that's right
what fees were you gonna
it's basically it's tax and legal fees
stamp duty is a tax
and then legal fees you're gonna have to
pay a solicitor
probably about maybe a thousand pounds
plus you're gonna have to potentially
pay a few hundred pounds to a mortgage
broker if you've got a broker so there's
a few costs
so what we're gonna say is we're gonna
say this we're gonna say that the
deposit is 25
but we're going to add another four
percent for tax and legal fees
now just to be really really clear this
will
vary from house to house stamp duty it
works on a sliding scale depending on
the house depending on
if you're a first time buyer a second
time buyer
if you're buying through a company there
are things that you can do to bring
stamp duty down
but just for simplicity as a rule of
thumb
we're going to say four percent for your
tax
and legal fees does that sound
reasonable give me a yes
or no all right great and as i say it
can vary massively
it could be five percent it could be two
percent
but four percent is about average okay
so
that's gonna mean deposit is fifty grand
four percent was four percent of 200
grand
8 000 pounds hassan thank you so you're
also going to need 8 000 pounds
so your total investment is going to be
58 000 pounds
to buy a 200 000 pound house
and that's 25 plus 4
minus the 200 000 so another way to work
this out would be like this you could
just say 29
of the total property so you could go
like this you could go um
so the property investment is 200 grand
and you can just go times point
um two nine
twenty nine percent that's 58 grand
that's how you could work it out
or you could even go 200 grand
times 30 what no not 31
uh sick is it 61 yeah six
see you don't you don't need to be smart
by the way or good at maths
to be really rich okay i use a at school
they'll tell you not to use a calculator
it's cheating
i'm like always use a calculator at
school they'll tell you not to copy the
kid next year that's cheating
in business we'll say find someone more
successful than you
and copy the heck out of them so
200 grams times .29
58 grand that's that's how you can work
it out so that's the total investment
is everyone clear on how to work out the
total investment